if you're launching a new business and
you're trying to figure out how do I get
it promoted I'm gonna share with you my
three-step ninja process for how to do
it for free
hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and I've
recently got a question from one of my
newsletter subscribers love you guys
Allen who wrote in to say you're making
a believer out of me
I believe I'm enjoying your emails your
morning startup ritual video product
hunts is an awesome site thanks for the
tip thanks Allen glad you're enjoying
man here's a question you're about to
launch accom ideally go through the SOE
sequence integrate social media do some
email marketing buy some online ads but
it doesn't get you listed on Digg
TechCrunch or product um besides those
three which sites in an entrepreneur be
targeting to get listed on Allen
fantastic question and I love the idea
of reaching out to influential media
social media websites to launch your
business and I would much rather hit
those than have you spending money on
ads and banners to drive people to your
site so I'm gonna share with you my
three-step ninja process number one is
make a list of influential people it's
great that you already have TechCrunch
and Digg and product tons I'd probably
add Kickstarter to that list if you are
trying to launch kind of in the text
space those are all very tech oriented
websites what I do though if you don't
have the connections into those guys is
start making a list of all the people
who are influential to your target
audience
so for example if you want to reach
entrepreneurs you would want to talk to
someone like me right I've got five
million views on my channel believe
nation is growing and I love supporting
and helping entrepreneurs who are
building resources and tools for
entrepreneurs but despite the size of my
audience I can't help everybody right if
you are not targeting entrepreneurs I'm
not the guy to work with one of my loyal
viewers recently asked me if he could
come to Toronto and train me
he is a self defense guy and has his
business training elite bodyguards for
people and he's pitched me to say hey
let me come to Toronto for a month and
I'll train you every day we'll make a
series and hopefully you can introduce
me to some people and the videos will
help spread my name the challenge for me
as much as I
helping out my viewers and I want to see
his business be successful I'm not the
right demographic for him right I don't
think too many a believ nation of you
guys are in need of elite self defense
bodyguards so he has to go and find that
list of people who are targeting his
specific audience and it also works to
get on those big sites like private hunt
instead of you trying to get out there
and build a name talk to the people who
are influential already on product hunt
and let them know about your product
number two is connect with them on
social media so once you built your list
instead of just write into them and
saying hey here's my new website what do
you guys think about it how can you
please promote me in your newsletter or
on your youtube channel or to your
Twitter feed you're reaching out to them
and just letting your name be known so
if they make youtube videos comments and
all the YouTube videos if they're
tweeting out a lot respond to their
tweets if they're asking questions give
them answers being part of the community
and be a known quantity so that when
they see your name when they see your
face they know who you are so for
example for you guys in believe nation
there's a lot of you who who post every
now and then and I look at all the
comments right I respond to pretty much
all the comments but there are some
people who comment on almost every
single video right and if you are
repeatedly commenting on my videos then
I'm gonna check it out right I'm gonna
look at your profile see what you're up
to I might leave a comment on one of
your videos the people who are
consistent and who are always leaving
responses I'm gonna go check them out
more you want to be that guy for the
people in your community right so
instead of pitching me to say hey
everyone here's this new website what do
you think if you are an active member of
my community I'm gonna be way more
receptive to answering your questions
and to lend in your hand so for that
list of people who you made contact with
you now want to add value and be a known
quantity so whenever they see your name
and whenever they see your face they
know exactly who you are and number
three ask them for their thoughts don't
pitch them don't write in this say hey
can you check out my site and promote it
to your audience that's the fastest way
to turn somebody off I can't tell you
how many times I
pitched on products and services and
people say this is going to be a
fantastic fit for your audience can you
please check it out and we'll give you a
25% Commission for everything that you
sell that's not what I'm interested in
right I don't want to be pitched but at
the same time
I love providing value to my audience I
love sharing things that I feel are
helping me as well as what I feel will
help them so the best way to stand out
now that you've made your list and now
that you have started reaching out to
them when they know who you are is you
ask for their help and you say hey I've
launched this website I'm targeting
these guys I'd love to know what you
think about it would you mind checking
it out and giving me your thoughts and
if you've done step number one and
number two right they're gonna go and
check it out and give me some feedback
and if they really like it then they're
gonna share it they're gonna find ways
to share it and talk about it that you
didn't even think we're possible because
they love what you're doing you know the
caveat here is this has to actually work
right your website has to be great
if you're telling me that this is a new
thing for entrepreneurs and it's really
amazing and you've been a lower part of
my community and I go check it out it's
got a deliverer right if it's not good
I'm not gonna talk about it right but if
it's great and I use it and I think it
could help other people then I will help
spread that message for you so that's my
three-step ninja process it's helped me
over and over and over and over again
and hope that it helps you to believe
those are you watching I'd love to hear
how you've connected with influencers
what strategies you've used to get your
name out there leave a comment below I'm
gonna join in the discussion and
hopefully will help inspire other
entrepreneurs as well and if you like
this video you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
the newsletter thank you so much for
watching I'll see you soon